da günaydın
[Alkış]
Sen beni net görebiliyor musunuz
mi Evet İrem burada mı İrem Aslan bana
havaalanında ne paketinden Orada mısın
yine
Tamam İrem gibi bizden daha net
görüyorum şu anda gözü sizden daha iyi
oldu ya da önde oturduğum için değil
Çünkü benimle konuştu yolda gelirken
konuştu konuştum beni görebildi bu benim
sizlerle paylaşmak istediğim en önemli
donuyor onun içinde konuşmanın başlığı
Konuş bir seni görebileyim dedi
gerçekten de insanlar önce biz
edenlerden başlayalım çünkü sizin ana
başlığımız bildiğinden fazlası fazlası
bölümüne sonra geliriz bildiklerimiz şu
insan sosyal bir varlık bir toplum
içinde yaşıyor Robinson artık bir efsane
Kimse yalnız değil küçük ya da büyük bir
toplum içinde bu toplumlarda ilişki
kurabilmesi ya da daha kardaşlı ile
iletişim kurabilmesi için de konuşması
lazım
konuşurken her türlü resim şekilleniyor
karşınızdakinin kafasında geldiniz en
pahalı için beni en büyük ihtimalle ya
tiyatro sahnesinde ya televizyon
ekranında yaşlarda gördüğünüz
gördüklerinizin hepsini bir oldu Onu iyi
oynadım kötü oynadım ve o benim
problemin ama siz orada bir Ekrem amca
seyrettiniz ya da kibarlık budalası
Messenger'dan seyrettiniz gerçek Hakan
Altıner ile konuşmanız belki sokakta
karşılaştık selamlaştık belki fotoğraf
çektirdik onun ötesinde beni görmedim
seni şimdi yavaş yavaş kamera ayağınız
başladı daha net görmeye başladınız
konuşmanın insan hayatındaki beş duyuya
yönelik önemli üzerinde durmak istiyoruz
Hüseyin ben yaklaşık 35 yıldır
tiyatroculuk mesleğinin yanı sıra
topluluk önünde konuşma dersleri veriyor
bu başlık sizi yanıltmasın topluluk
önünde konuşma Eski Türkçe'de söyleyelim
Hitabe ile büyük bir topluluğa hitap
etme sanatı değil iki kişilik bir
konuşmada Çok ciddi bir topluluk önünde
konuşma olabilir güncel bir örnek
verelim
o kızın babasıyla tanışacaksınız
niyetiniz çok ciddi Baba hakkında bir
yöne yardımsız var doğru ise dizleriniz
titriyor ve hayatınızın konuşmasını
yapacaksınız İşte bu topluluk önünde
konuşma the çalışmamız gereken bir
konuşmadır üzerinde uğraşmanız gereken
bir konuşma dıb Daha güncelleştir elim
taksiye bildiğiniz Taksi şoförleri
hakkında bir yargınız var Ve şuanda
İstanbulda yaşıyorsanız Ben aynı
yargılarınız var Hayır taksiye
bildiğiniz Siz Günaydın Günaydın efendim
Ne tarafa Gideceğiz dedi şoför görmeye
başladım başka bir insan bunun negatif
etkisi de tabi olabilir ama biz bugün
olumlu kalmaya devam edelim Bu kadar
olumlu güzel İnsanların olduğu bir
ortamda negatif etkiler yayalım
etrafımıza Peki Madem ki bu iletişimi
yapacağız Bu konuşmanın topluluk önünde
konuşma nın küçücük sırları neden şey
yaklaşık dediğim gibi 35 yıldır uzun
derslerde anlattığım şeyi burada size
çok kısa da 18 dakika için Hoş geldin
değil 10 satır başlarıyla gidelim şimdi
belki çoğunuz da biliyorsunuz ama
bildiğinizden fazlası bölümü geliyor bir
kere herkesin çerkezin de geldim ama
benimle muhatap olan insanların 199 unun
şöyle bir şikayet var herhangi bir
konuda konuşacağım bir konferans
Vereceğim bir şey anlatacağım şükür
Bugün ilk beş dakikada çok
heyecanlanıyorum efesı kalmaya başlıyor
söyle giderek sesim kısılıyor Ben bunu
nasıl halledebilirim
aynı cevabı veriyorum bir kere sesinin
kısılması diye tabir ettiğimiz şey
aramızda Doktorlar varsa ukalalığı
bağışlasın ama ses tellerimiz dediğimiz
kaslarla alakası olmayan bir şey sessiz
kısılmıyor efesinin size hizmet etmiyor
ya size hizmet etmediği için de
almak ihtiyacını duyuyorsunuz O Ses
kısılması dediğimiz şey Ancak enfeksiyon
varsa söz konusu normal yok ha Peki bir
başka örneği doğru gidelim bebeklerin
ağlamalarını de böyle dakikalarda feryat
figan ağlayan var ya sesi kısılan bebek
gördünüz mü Ben görmedim Hatta anne baba
yani Allah'ın bir sus ya diye perişan
olurlar Ama susmak Neden Çünkü doğumla
birlikte O henüz toplum koşulları
tarafından yozlaştırılması için ya bizi
Diyaframdan alıyor Yaprağım dediğimiz
hepiniz biliyorsunuz şu baş
parmaklarınızı en altta bugün uzak oyun
5 parmağımızı açın benimki kadar göbekli
olmanız şart değil ama kapsadığını Sayer
diyafram o diyafram sizin doğuştan var
olan nefes yapıyoruz ama zaman içinde
dediğim gibi toplumsal koşullanmalar
koşuşturmalar nefes nefese kalmalar labu
işimizi de biz programı bir tarafa
geçiyorum şu akciğerlerimize gidiyoruz
Yine Doktor olanlar belaların başlasın
ama akciğerlerin o kadar çok hizmeti ve
fonksiyonu var ki bu arada bir yandan da
siz önemli bir konuşma yaparken senin
bestep oluyor zaten
Ne diyeceğimi oyuncu sanız özellikle
tiyatro sahnesinde çıkıyorsanız bunun
çok daha ciddi içinde yer alması lazım
Peki ne yapmamız lazım işte üç ana
dolayı biliyoruz sizi ister topluluk
önünde ister çok ciddi bir konuşmanın
arefesinde yardım edecek üç tane şeyimiz
var Bunlardan bir tanesi çok önemli
nefesi dediğim gibi nefesinizi
Diyaframdan almaya çalışacaksınız çok
zor bir şey değildir egzersizde
edilir onunla ilgili internette onlarca
videolar çok basit yani
Nefes alırken elinizi dediğim yere
diyafram bölgenize koyun ama göbeğinizi
şişirecek mis gibi nefes almayın doğal
nefes alın bir süre oranın kıpırdamadı
görüyorsun diğerlerini çalışıyor Bir
süre sonra beyin o koklamayı verir Aşağı
ineceğiz aşağıya ilk biriktir biriktir
çok kısa bir süre içinde diye
programınızı kullanmaya başlarsınız
Ancak bu çok ömür boyu uzun süreli bir
egzersizdir ve yine görüşürüz Yani ben
konservatuvardan çok yıl oldu ama gayet
ne satılıyor ilk dersimiz den başlayarak
yaklaşık bir yıl sahne dersimizde Nur
içinde yatsın Yıldız Kenter'in dersinde
ilk yaptığımız iş 20 dakika diyafram
egzersizi yaptık Yaptık yaptık yaptık
Sonra çoğumuzun başına gelen İzlerinde
başına geldi diyelim ki Bir yılın
sonunda
hastalandı doktora gittik Doktor da
klasik ses kokulu taktı nefes aldığında
aldık nefes olayım lazım dedi adı
almıyorsun duymuyorum dedi Çünkü artık
yatırımınız çalışıyor akciğerler öyle
bir fonksiyonu ileri götürmüyorlar
burada Tabii çok zararlı olduğu yüzdeyüz
kesin olan sigaranın da katkılarını
istiyorsanız bu işe katarsak diyaframı
kullanmamanız artık sizin için
kaba davranmak istemiyorum ama satılık
diyelim satılık olacaktır biraz daha
kafa davransaydın aptallık olacaktır
verdim çünkü kullanılması en kolay
organlar Bu seferki almışım O benim
ikinci dönmeye geliyoruz o çok önemli
ikinci söyle de en büyük yardımcınız
omurganız dik durma hikayesi yine
sevgiyle saygıyla analım Yıldız hocanın
55 yıllık konservatuvar eğitimi z31
zaman sırtımızda eksik olmadı dolaşırken
egzersiz yaparken falan değil
çalıştırırken Dik dur dik dur dik dur
çok basit dik durduğunu zaman seyirciye
sizi izleyenler
oyuncu olun açık oluyorsunuz seyirci
sizden Eğer bir rol gereği gımbıl kambur
vesaire oynuyorsanız sizden bir onları
yayılan güven duygusunu alıyor bu
güvenilir bir adam açık ve bütün
hücreler çıktım dik duruyor bundan
herhangi bir kötülük gelmez o dik durma
meselesi seyircinin size olan güvenini
arttırır Ama siz de kisi çok daha
fazladır sizin özgüveniniz arttır zaten
bu üç tane birleştiği zaman Çünkü de
şimdi söyleyeceğim Özgüven problemi
kalmayan insanlara dönüşecek siniz Hayat
içinde Onun için Hadi piyatro hayattır
Hayat yapıyordu gibi sloganların altında
yatar ya da biraz önce arkadaşımızın
söylediği gibi çeksin Bütün dünya bir
sahnedir Bizler kadınlar ve erkekler
girip çıkan oyuncular pembesinin altında
yatan tamamen budur hayat içinde bunun
herhalde farkındasınızdır ama ben bir
kere daha gideyim Hayat içinde belli
roller oynuyoruz bu burada yerimiz yere
kişilere muhatap olacağımız İnsanları
böyle değişiyor Örneğin siz beni bugün
konuşmacı Hakan Altıner kimliğini
görüyor Ve tanıyorsunuz asıl Hakan
Altıner Ben daha farklı bir adamdır
Çünkü ben bu rolü yıllardır oynuyorum ve
program ediyorum sizin huzurunuza
çıkmadan önce de bir alışkanlığın
verdiği pompalı kapılmadım En azından Ne
yapalım Ne konuşurum nasıl toparlarım 18
dakikaya nasıl sıcak bir keşke birisi
Bana karşıdan süren bitiyor plan
desenize ver ha yapsa bunu çok rahat
edeceğim sondaki bana gösterirsen ben de
rahat edeceğim bu tür yardımlarla nasıl
yapabileceğime dair kafamda bir pro
çizelgesi çıkardı sizlerse üçüncüde
oraya geliyorum öpersiniz doğru
kullandığınız birimlik durdunuz
açıksınız seyirciye jestlerden
kaçırmayın El kol hareketlerinden
gereken yerde yapın 3. bölgede 3. günü
Gözleriniz arkadaşlar çok temizdir iyi
oyunculara da bu dersi verirken haklı
olarak bazı genç oyuncu arkadaşlarım
hocam yapmayın Allah aşkına 550 kişilik
bir salonda oynuyoruz 500 49 numaralı
Koltukta oturan zaten Beni şuradan
çıkıyor koca bir afet gözümü nerden
görecekler bende hep aynı cevabı veririm
gözünü görmesi gerekmez gözünün yaydığı
ışığı hissedecektir size mistik bir şey
gibi gelmesin gerçekten insanlar
bakışlarıyla çok şeyi anlatırlar Yani
herhangi bir basit bir örnek verelim
Seni seviyorum güzel biraz değil mi ve
siz iyilikle söylemek istiyorsunuz Seni
seviyorum diyorsunuz ama gözlerini söyle
bir bakıyor ki içinden Yani şimdilik
basit idare ediyoruz ama sevip
sevmediğimi çok emin değil mi Bak şu var
ya da tam tersi çok öfkelendiğiniz Bir
de partnerinize karşınızdaki
arkadaşınıza sevgilinize Eşinize
İnanmıyorum sana diyorsun Evet
ama Gözleriniz Aslında inanıyorum de
işime gelmiyor diyor Bunları
bu tarafta algılaması ele Yakınız bir
ise mümkün bunu İnanın bana güvenip
söyleyeceğim yapa birebir konuşmada
karşınızdaki algılar 1 milyon kişiye
hitap ediyorsanız onlarda algılarlar
Çünkü yaşayacağınız enerji ile
alakalıdır ve siz doğru çıkıyor indik
duruyorsunuz Gözleriniz dediğinizi
tasdik ediyor arkadaşlar size önümüzdeki
günlerde aydınlık yepyeni bir Nesi var
ediyorum derken gözünüzde vaad ediyorsa
gözünüzü boşver ifade edelim Bunlar oy
versinler birisi kolay demiyorsa Buse
karşıya bu seyirciye bu dinleyeceğiz
geçtiği zaman artık sizin toplum önünde
bir konuşma yaparken hata yapma
ihtimaliniz bayağı Sıfıra yakın Neden
Çünkü bunlar var Bu üçü beraber sizin
özgüveniniz oluşturuyorlar çıkıyorsunuz
tepesine misiniz durdunuz Gözlerinize bu
aynası dolayısıyla çok rahat bir şekilde
siz bu konuşmayı 18 dakika da
yapabilirsiniz
karşılığı diğer uyumamışsın Bu saatte
yapabilirsiniz ama hiçbir zaman başımıza
kaldı Kanadım kalbim çarpıyor ne
yapacağım Gelmez çünkü o kalbinizin
çarpmasını aynı şekilde sesinizin
diyelim pürüzlenmesi önleyen de polis
çalışıyor ha Ama hayat o kadar kolay
neden değil Onu da söylüyor Şimdi Bütün
bunlar ihtiyaç yolcularla en çok dalga
geçilen konulardan biridir Ne yapıyorsun
provaya gidiyorum hangi tavsiye
gidiyorsun plan gibi böyle anlamsız
espriler yaparlar
prova
oyuncular için kutsaldır bunu mistik bir
şekilde söylüyorum demin o hazırlanma
süreci bir futbolcunun antrenmanı ne
kadar onun için önemliyse ya da bir
sporcu nokta futbolcu diye de kısıtlama
Yalım tiyatrocu için oyuncu için yani
sahneye çıkacak içinde o Bu arada
sürekli o kadar önemli Biz burada ne
yapıyoruz biz burada bir sözün değil
talimatlarıyla önümüze kalan bir Tekstil
birebir ezberleyerek Çünkü ezberleme s
karşımızdaki de aynı şekilde
söyleyeceğim lafı kolay hazırlayamaz
bunu türlü altıya doğru akşama
Tiyatroları filan dışında tutuyorum ve
dramatik piyasada bunu yapıyoruz Çok
ciddi bir ezber yapıyoruz bu zaten
vaktimizi alıyor hiç bir oyun bugüne
kadar böyle
sıkıştırılmak niyeti Yoksa 30 provadan
aşağı çıkmamıştır benim eliçabuk
bireysel olduğundan bahsederler Öyle
yapmaya çalışıyorum ama mesela dün
problemlerini yaptığım Halide Edip
Adıvar'ın Türk'ün Ateşle İmtihanı adlı
oyunu ki iki kişilik oyun provası
yaklaşık
55-60 arasında değişti sebebi tek tek
tek duyguları Pro etmemizi o duyguları
içeren cümleleri problemi Siz konuşmacı
olarak Burada herhangi bir bu konuşma
yaptığınızı varsayarak bunu söylüyorum
tiyatrocularla bir yol ayrımına geldiniz
oyunculuktan ayrılan tarafı bu Biz
birebir TX bağlıyız bağlı olmak
zorundayız anlattığım nedenlerle Ama siz
Sakın ha İzver yapmayın bir konuşma
yapacaksınız dünyanın en kolay ön
yargıdır çağırır işte değilmiş sizin
patronunuz hocanız
Önümüzdeki 29 Ekim'de Atatürk devrimleri
ve özellikle de haftaya yapacaksınız
dedi tamam zaten bildiğiniz Aşina
olduğumuz bir konudur orada siz ya ben
bir Siz de çok kolay ezberledim şöyle
Aldım messi'den önüme koyalım şimdi
kullanılan bir takım
kastetmiyorum onları yapan şeyler ölme
koyarım takır sakız anlatırım Hayır öyle
olmaz çünkü zihin o kadar enteresan bir
sisteme sahip ki ezberler Seniz Eğer bir
şeyi ve bir şey sizin dikkatinizi
dağıtırsa bırakıyorsunuz Biz tiyatroda
buna oyunculukları naturak gelmek
istiyoruz sen beni bilmiyorum Çok geldin
bir oyuncunun çok sık olmamakla beraber
mutlaka yüzleştiği bir felakettir ve
size yine bir oyuncu olarak deneyimli
bir oyuncu olarak o anki hissi şöyle
tanımlayabilirim ben neredeyim Ne
yapıyorum yani Tekstil şurası unuttum
Ayşe'nin lafı neydi falan yapamazsınız
öyle bir blokaj beyninizde şey diyorlar
mavi ekran bu ne öyle deyimler var
zihniniz öyle oldu konuşmacı bu asla
yüklemeniz gereken bir felaket değil
onun için konuyu artık olacaksınız
anlatacağız Şehit kapandı bizim kafamıza
gideceksiniz ama asla ve asla
ezberleyeceksin genellikle kendinize
güvendiğiniz konu bir konuşmanın Ne
konuşacağım bölümdür yani Ne anlatacağım
bölümü
bilgi ve deneyimleriniz dahilinde bir
şey önerir misin size duyan
öldü elini cebine sok Anladım öyle değil
işte benim size burada özellikle
anlatmaya çalıştım Ne bölümü değil Nasıl
ölümü Bu nasıl bölümünü daha fazla
uzatmadan ne bölümü ile ilgili Önemli
bir detay vermek istiyorum örnek Ben
burada konuşmaya başlarken Günaydın
dedim size Çünkü ben A bu saat oldu
adamın kafası sabahta kalmış filan
durumunda değilim Ben gün boyunca
karşılaştığı insanlara günaydın diyorum
Çünkü o o Günün aydınlık geçmesi
dileğini içeren bir sözcük eğer sırf
sabaha olsaydı o sözcük sabah Aydın
olurdu ama bizi şartlanma ile Günaydın
işte karşılaştığımız zaman ilk yataktan
kalktığınız sokağa çıktığımız zaman
söylenen bir arttırıyoruz Yani bir çok
rahat koyuyoruz bir sakıncası yok Neden
bir sakıncası yok Biliyor musunuz işte
ne bölümüne önemli anahtarı kelime
hazinenizi bunu da hemen bilmeyenler
için düzelttim bu kelime hazinesi olarak
kullanıyorlar hazireti kelime haznesi
kelime kapı kelime hazinenizi
genişletilmesi lazım ve Bana inanın
kelimelerle onlardan üreteceğimiz
fikirler genişledikçe dünyanın da
genişliğini göreceksiniz Kendinizi çok
daha rahat ifade ettiğinizi göreceksiniz
ve Aslında dünyayı kelimeler ve onların
oluşturduğu fikirlerin yönettiğini idrak
edeceksiniz türkçemizin miydi nankörlük
etmeyelim 6000 den fazla kelime var O
bir araştırmada okumuştum hala Doğrudur
tahmin ediyorum biz güncel hayata 300
kelimeyle konuşuyormuş hafta 6000 var
bilmediğimiz de 6000 değil yeniden
öğrenmemiz gereken Belki eski deyimler
falan olabilir ama şöyle bir hazine var
bir günlük hayatta onunla konuşuyoruz
Hele ki hayatımıza son dönemde
mesajlaşmalarda plan gider o kısaltmalar
var ya Yani çok merak ediyorum bir
mesajı yazarken sevgiler yazmak kaç
saniye sürüyor her iki şimdiki
canavarlarını elinde Hayır SV yazıyor
nokta koydu Ben onu alacağım
ilgilendirmez ya da işte Öpüyorum e Prf
Ama bu tamamen tembel konuşmanızda da
aynı şekilde sadece 300 filmin içinde de
ve dik durursanız bu tembelliği işaret
eder bu tembelliği yapın Hayat her şeyi
Emek gerektiriyor çalışmak gerekiyorsa
zor bir çalışma değil bu o zaman
okulunuz genişleyecek Yaza bir şeyden
bahsediyorsun sen hangi bir şey olur ya
çok üzgünüm başka bir gün kelime yok mu
O çok mu geliştirmeniz lazımsa insan
sadece üzgün olmaz değil mi aynı şekilde
çok sorumluluk duydum Çok mütebessim
eskilerin deyimiyle ben bundan çok büyük
düz biliyor alternatif var Çok üzgünüm
bir geçiyoruz iki yabancı dillerden
özellikle dublaj yapılan filmlerde ağız
uydurmak derdiyle televizyon kanalında
zihnimize giren şeyler var ki bunlar
Türkçede yok Selam diye biraz yoktu
Selamün Aleyküm selam selamı Tek
kelimeyle hain yerine koydum
daha güzel bir şey söyleyeyim öptüm
öptüm
öptüm öptüm sizi
[Müzik]
Hoş geldiniz daha ileri kısırlaşma
Sınana çıkıyor bu Bir tehlike arkadaşlar
sadece dilimiz Azra tehlike değil Sizin
adınıza Bir tehlike yarın öbür gün
herhangi bir şekilde Gerçekten böyle bir
topluluk önünde konuşma yapacağınız
zaman kullanacağınız kelimenin azıcık
olması adeta kredi kartı limit izin çok
sınırlı olması ile işte ya da
anlatacaksınız Ee dikkat edin kitap
diyecekler ki bildiğiniz şeyler söylüyor
yani değişik bir şey yoktu değişik bir
şey gitti bir konuşmada Sizden ne
bekliyorlar soğuk yapmanızı değil Niye
sadece o belli kelimelerle konuştuğunuz
biraz ufku geniş etmediniz bunun da
yöntemi yolu neydi Ne bölümün yöntemi
yolu bol miktarda Özellikle de size
Roman
Türk edebiyatı çok zengin olan
külliyatının sahip olanlar üzerinde
Okumakla kalmayın lütfen düşünün Ben
olsaydım nasıl yazardım Ben olsaydım
bunu çok beğendim bırakın ormanın
üslubunda yepyeni sizin için Romanlar
çıksın Bunlar birden bire parasal
karşılık olarak günümüzde Artık tek
geçerli ölçüt o size geri dönmeyebilir
ama kariyer adına ilişkiler adına ve en
önemlisi sevdiklerinizin oluşturduğu
küçücük toplumdaki prestijini zâtına
size geri dönecektir ki hiç kimse bunun
değersiz bir şey olduğunu iddia etme
zannediyorum Sizler de çok kısa
çökmüştür dedi paylaştığım hikayeden
aklınızda o kalsın istiyorum 3 ödemenizi
hiç unutmayın ihmal etmeyin nefes omurga
göz konuşacağız konuda mutlaka pro-v
Diplomasız yakalanmayın hayata
rolünüzü pro-v ederek başlayıp her şeyde
ve her konuda ve lütfen unutmayın kişi
kalsın istiyorum yaptığımıza Konuş bir
seni görebileyim hayatımızın düşürülür
bilginize Çok teşekkür ederim Çok memnun
oldum burada olmuş abi
abone ol